now if you're looking for a new place to
escape during this holiday season we've
got you covered travel expert Sarah
dandashi shares more
some people stay local during the
holidays others travel to see family and
then there are those who see this as an
opportunity to just get away whatever
your reason is to get out of town here
are a few hotels that have really gotten
into the holiday spirit with packages so
unique you just might want to add them
to your list
a quick flight to Orange County make a
trip to the Ritz Carlton Laguna Niguel
where you can make it a Seaside Holiday
from gingerbread workshops to teddy bear
tea services and of course Gourmet
feasts on Christmas Eve Christmas and
New Year's they even offer a sweet
package where you can have a Christmas
tree a real Christmas tree placed in
your room along with elf special
delivery of packages and just when you
thought you wouldn't even want to leave
the property it's located not too far
away from the famous South Coast Plaza
mall where you can treat yourself to a
luxury shopping spree in style making
this a great option for celebrating the
holidays at the coast
but of course if you're looking for the
full snowy winter experience head up to
Whistler Canada the Delta Whistler
Village Suites is not only home to the
Whistler blackcomb ski resort you're
also just steps away from Whistler
Village which is truly like walking
through a real life snow globe you can
come for the perfect location and of
course stay for the hot cocoa served
daily sign me up for that but from
skiing to ice skating snowshoeing or
even taking a break in the famous
scandinav Spa which is a must by the way
when you're playing in the snow Whistler
is the ultimate winter vacation
Now for Something Completely Different
head to Dallas and check out the
historic and iconic Adolphus Hotel which
is celebrating their 110th year
anniversary since opening in 1912 it's
the original site of City Hall the
Adolphus Hotel is known for its elegance
and exceptional service even the late
Queen Elizabeth stayed there in 1991.
you can take part in one of Dallas's
most revered holiday traditions by
having holiday tea at their famous
French room or just have a good
old-fashioned Cowboy lunch at the rodeo
bar either way the Adolphus truly is a
destination in and of itself when in
Dallas
so there you have it hopefully this has
given you a few ideas that you might not
have thought of there's still time to
plan if you're looking for something a
little bit different this holiday season
if you want to find out more check out
my blog at askacontiers.tv